this is a production of Cornell
University
hi everyone welcome again to the 2023
hemp webinar series my name is Feliz
monserrate a second year PhD student in
plant reading and genetics in Larry
Smart Lab at corner University I am
accompanied by Alum Antonio Barraco who
has assisted me putting this webinar
together by also by Kim and Gemma who
have provided this digital platform for
us to to have our webinar series and
today we have a special guest my advisor
Dr Larry smart professor of Lamborghini
genetics Sacramento University
and lastly I just want to mention that
this webinar is a component of a larger
project which is the development of
educational modules that will be freely
available on the account website at the
end of this webinar series each module
will consist of the recorded webinar the
instructional slave egg and a couple of
high impact papers pertaining to the
respective subject for instance in this
case it would be hemp diseases
all women recorded will be available on
the Cornell sips YouTube channel if
you're interested in re-watching them or
sharing them with someone that could not
attend so with that it is my pleasure to
introduce Patrick McMillan he is a PhD
candidate alcohol University in Plant
Pathology increases Smart Lab
unfortunately Chris is going to join us
could not join us today
uh due to the scheduling conflicts which
is why Patrick is presenting on her
behalf and his thought today is going to
be on him diseases so Patrick without
any further Ado take it away
thank you Elise and it's great to have
everyone here today for this talk so
um like Louise said I'm a third year PhD
candidate here at Cornell University in
Chris Smart's lab where I study
primarily pythium damping off on hemp
and pythm root rots
um today I'll be covering a bunch of
different diseases that we see on him
and showing characteristics of them and
some of what you can do to manage these
diseases If You observe them in your
Growing System a lot of this work has
been done by other collaborators in my
lab previous grad student Ali Calla
current student Jocelyn Schwartz
text column Day Taylor Herman and Chris
smart advisor
so I know for the um the posting for
this talk we made the disclaimer that we
aren't going to be focusing on hoppley
and thyroid
which is becoming an increasingly
prevalent issue across the country
however we haven't yet seen this in New
York state so um we're not researching
this here but I did just want to mention
a couple things about hopley and viroid
here right at the beginning
so on the left here is just a healthy
plant that was not infected with hopley
and thyroid it was mock inoculated
um here on the right is one that is
infected with hopley and thyroid
and you can see that this infected plant
shows smaller fan leaves and a leaf
eponasticity
um in the plants infected with this
viroid so while this is seen in some
parts of the country but not here there
is work going on in some other labs and
there's some great Publications in the
viruses Journal
right
so first I'd just like to give a general
overview of what I'll be covering
through the remainder of this talk
um so I'll begin with a very brief
pathogen Concepts overview to just
preview the types of things I'll be
talking about
then I'll move into examples of
bacterial diseases followed by fungal
diseases which are our most common
diseases on hemp water molds or oh myc
pathogens
and then I'd like to share some research
results from experiments that were
conducted here at Cornell including my
own research on lithium damping off
so what do you need to know to reduce
hemp diseases in your Growing System
well first it's important to think about
what types of things that a pathogen
needs in order to infect a plant so
plant Pathologists often like to think
of this concept in something that we
refer to as the disease triangle
so in order for disease to occur there's
three components that are essential
you need a susceptible post-cultivar so
a cultivar of that's susceptible to
whatever particular pathogen
you need that pathogen to be present and
you need a virulent strain of it there's
a virulent strains of pathogens around
that might not infect even if it is a
susceptible host cultivar
and then finally you need a favorable
favorable environment
so pathogens often require certain
conditions whether that's moisture
content or temperature in order for them
to successfully infect a plant
so without all three of those components
coming together you won't see disease
occurring
yeah
um so then moving on uh things that you
should be considering when you want to
develop management plans for your
particular growing system
it's important to know what pathogens
are common on your farm or in your area
um what have other neighboring Growers
seen in recent years or what have you
seen year to year keeping some sort of
record of that can be very helpful
knowing the rotation of the rotation
history of the field you're planting in
can be important some pathogens can
survive on multiple hosts whereas others
have a very limited Host range so
knowing what pathogens have been there
and how they overwinter is important to
management as well
um like I mentioned just before
environmental conditions are very
important for diseases to occur
so knowing what pathogens are in your
area and as well as what types of
environment you normally see
all contribute to this and that becomes
a little bit more difficult as we see a
greater variability in climate season to
season right now
so then when we're considering managing
the pathogens that we do have cultural
practices are often our best bet at
reducing pathogen pressure
so things like avoidance uh not avoiding
the pathogen itself not planting in very
wet areas
um pruning those sorts of things that
we'll discuss more in detail in the
coming slides
and then finally a chemical control is
our last fallback so what products can
we use to control diseases that you
expect to see in your field
and is there any efficacy data
supporting
um the efficacy of products registered
for hemp disease is common in your area
now it's important to know that there
aren't as many registered pesticides
available for hemp as in other crops
however this number is growing and it's
always just important to make sure you
read the pesticide product label and
follow all instructions for your
location
so the first group of pathogens I would
like to talk about are diseases caused
by bacterial pathogens
one that we've seen here in New York
recently is serration more assassins
which causes this necrosis on the leaf
tissue and Wilt and senescence of the
leaf when we plate this out we often see
these white to pinkish colonies growing
in culture
marcessins is usually seen early in the
season and it drives mostly in cool wet
years
so as the summer progresses and it warms
up a little bit we usually see less of
this disease
um as the as the disease progresses and
this necrotic area moves across the leaf
spreads across the leaf tissue
the leaf will eventually uh senes can
fall off after losing some of these
infected leaves the plant is often able
to grow out of this disease and
shouldn't really become too much of an
issue unless the environment is very
favorable for
this disease in a particular year
there's also a number of bacterial Leaf
spots that have been observed there's
several different species of bacteria
that can cause Leaf spots such as these
where you see black lesions on the leaf
surface
um some of the bacterial species such as
pseudomonas cannabina can cause disease
on other crop plants as well
while we have observed um some of these
Leaf spots they're not terribly common
in this area
so bacterial pathogens have yet to be
well characterized in hemp and
understand their biology and
epidemiology in order to inform
management strategies they haven't
become kind of the overarching prevalent
disease group
that infects him fungal pathogens
however are much more common and there's
a wide array of them that are very
problematic to Growers
one of the most common
um fungal Leaf spots in hemp is septoria
leaf spot
it's caused by the fungus septoria
cannabis
they form these lesions on the leaves
that have a brown necrotic Center
followed by yellow Halo
eventually these lesions will coalesce
and lead to defoliation of the leaves
the spores are spread via wind and
splashing of rain
and this pathogen can overwinter in the
soil so this is where knowing your
previous
crop rotation in your Fields is
important
removing leaves or branches near the
base of the plant and thinning the plant
to increase airflow will help reduce the
disease
and here's just an image of someone
pruning off some dense foliage in order
to increase airflow in the plant
so here's a more up close image of the
subtoria leaf spot I'm seeing this
lesion with the characteristic dark
brown or black dots in the center of it
here in those darkened areas are where
the fungal spores are contained and
these are released from these structures
during periods of leaf wetness so the
wetness is really important in order for
this pathogen to spread onto neighboring
leaves and neighboring plants
currently a student in our lab is
working on screening some
sessions of hemp about 75 different
cultivars for resistance to septatorial
leaf spot
to look for any kind of genetic
resistance that can inform breeders
to incorporate into their cultivars
and we're also testing biofungicides for
efficacy to control this pathogen as
well so hopefully we'll have more
exciting news in the coming years on how
to control this very common leaf spot
another common leaf spot that is
observed is by Polaris leaf spot caused
by the fungus freshlyric egantia now
that might seem a little bit confusing
with the nomenclature here but fungal
taxonomy is always changing so the names
um
don't necessarily line up but this is
often commonly referred to as bipolaris
leaf spot
the lesions here on the leaves that you
see from biplayers are much smaller than
those of serratia
sorry
um and they usually have this yellow
color
compared to other Leaf spots which are
darker these can infect other plants
including weed species as well
um so in
scenarios like this weed control is very
important because you don't want a dense
coverage of weeds that can Harbor
pathogens and infect your crop
like many other fungal pathogens
bipolaris is favored by wet weather
and then another leaf spot for Studio
area is very common under certain
climate conditions we saw a lot of this
in 2021 here in New York it forms these
very distinct Target shaped lesions with
concentric circles so it's pretty easy
to distinguish from the others that we
talked about
like the other Leaf spots it can cause
defoliation
um when it progresses far enough
this does have other hosts including
maple trees so you might see this if
you're growing close to a wooded area
however very little is known about the
impact of the pathogen on pemp yet as
far as yield reductions or how prevalent
it is really we've just observed this a
number of times in the region
so another interesting foliar pathogen
of hemp is hemp rust now rusts are very
important and need to be controlled
heavily on grain crops like wheat wheat
rust is a very problematic issue on hemp
it often isn't as severe
where it forms these pustules on the
underside of leaves and can cause
defoliation
um
and yield reductions in very severe
outbreaks
um but typically you're only seeing
small amounts of it
the uh
the causal species of hempress is urido
krigariana
it forms orange colored spores on the
underside of the leaves that form these
larger pustules once it's on the leaf it
can spread throughout this Leaf tissue
and the spores are wind blown to other
neighboring leaves and plants
a little is known about the pathogen
life cycle of this particular species on
hemp right now some rest have
alternative hosts that they need a
second plant species to complete its
life cycle on this species just has not
been studied enough yet for us to know
those details
and like I mentioned it's not most the
or among the most common pathogens that
we see here in New York but we have
found it a couple times
a pathogen that is very common and
infects the flower buds of the plant the
inflorescence is gray mold caused by but
try to scenario
so when botrius first infects you'll see
this characteristic gray mold where it
gets its name from covering the
inflorescence of the plant which will
eventually turn into Brown necrotic
tissue making this flower Bud totally
unmarkable
um so this can be very problematic for
Growers uh particularly in very humid
climates or this can be seen A Lot in
controlled environment agriculture
anywhere where there's a lot of moisture
um we see this more in cultivars with
very tight floral development
um so anywhere where it can trap in a
lot of moisture and prevent increased
airflow will be a perfect environment
for botritis develop
and you'll see greater fungal
sporulation rain or higher humidity
this pathogen shouldn't be confused with
fusarium head blight which is a similar
inflorescence infecting pathogen
so fusarium head Blake and Bud blight
is caused by several species of fusarium
these fungi can produce dangerous
mycotoxins and cereals and other grains
and the species that do infect hemp are
known to cause these mycotoxins however
it hasn't been studied yet whether
mycotoxins are produced on hemp and
fluorescences yet there's currently some
wonderful research being done on
fusarium Headlight by Nicole goche's lab
down in the University of Kentucky
um so for more information on fusarium
bud blade I would strongly recommend
looking at some of her work in her lab's
work
um it's very important to be aware of
potential mycotoxin uh form uh
mycotoxins forming
because these are very dangerous to any
livestock that you might be marketing
grain for or in other uh
food products
we don't really know how common this is
yet in New York we haven't conducted
much many population biology studies or
study the epidemiology of this as you're
probably getting the gist of what a lot
of these pathogens we're just beginning
to study a lot of them
um one more pathogen that infects the
inflorescence and well
essentially the whole
above ground portion of hemp is white
mold white mold has a very very broad
oast range so crop rotation probably
isn't going to help you in this instance
um
it can infect many different crops
it's caused by the fungus sclerotinius
claridioreum
white mold infects the stem of the plant
where it can clog the veins of the plant
that prevent water flow from reaching
the upper shoots of the plant so as it
cuts off the water flow from the upper
shoots you'll see the plants start to
die from the top down
and you'll also see this characteristic
white mycelo growth over the stem of the
plant if you break open the stem you'll
often find these hard black
pieces that are part of the fungus
itself they're the sclerosis or the
hearty overwintering spores of this
fungus so those will fall down to the
soil and allow this this pathogen to
overwinter and survive year to year
so moving on from foliar and floral
pathogens
I'd like to move to some root and Crown
infecting diseases
so while I mentioned just before that
there's some species of fusarium that
infect the bud of the plant there's also
species that infect the crown and roots
of him
some of these species include fusarium
oxus from seleni and proliferatum
we've seen a lot of this across grower
fields in New York and in some of our
own field trials
um this is often observed by a Browning
and wilting of the shoots of the plant
and total plant collapse eventually if
you dig up the plant you'll see some
reddening and Browning on the roots and
overall reduced root biomass
so similar to what I discussed about
white mold blocking off the water flow
of the plant
fusarium will do this also but starting
at a much lower point in the plant
so it will infect the veins or the roots
and block off the water flow through the
veins and causing wilting and eventual
plant collapse
this is most often seen when you have
very small root development so if
there's if there's weak Roots going into
your field in the beginning of the
Season you might be your plants might be
more susceptible to some of these root
crops
a similar pathogen that causes root rot
and plant collapse are pythium root rots
it's important to note that pythium
isn't a true fungus it's an O Micey or a
water mold which I'll discuss more
coming up
um root rot and larger plants can be
observed in the field like this here
um in smaller seedling production you
can often see damping off caused by the
same species of lithium which I'll
discuss later on
and root bound transplants can be very
weak like I showed in the previous slide
where you have small root development
going into the field those plants will
often be weak and more susceptible to
pythium and your other root rots
it's also possible to have co-infection
with some of these pathogens or a lot of
these pathogens actually
um so from this plant we were able to
isolate both pythium and fusarium
both contributing to the death of this
plant
some management strategies I'd recommend
for root rots well first we would always
rely on some genetic resistance of host
cultivars which we don't really have
available to us at this time I'm sure we
will in the future but right now there's
not great host resistance now
so we heavily rely on good sanitation
practices so don't move soil between
Fields clean your farming equipment well
ensure adequate drainage in the field as
these pathogens usually really like
saturated soil and wet areas
crop rotation might help these uh these
pathogens often have wide host ranges
but depending on what you're planting
it might work
labeled fungicides with substantial
efficacy data are limited like for most
of the other pathogens on hemp
um but there are some options available
just refer to product labels and
resources from your local extension
agents
and as I mentioned several times be sure
to have a healthy root system at
planting that's kind of your best way to
ensure success going on
um there are some products that can
control fusarium I hear this was a lab
in vitro assay showing that copper can
inhibit fusarium growth at least in
culture in the lab so here on the right
our fusarium colonies on media with no
copper added and then as we move across
to the left there's increasing
concentrations of copper so where you
see the smaller Circle in the center
that shows that there's smaller fungal
growth
suppressed by the copper
so there are some potential
treatment management strategies for
these pathogens
I'd now like to move on to diseases
caused by water molds or oh my seats
um so one that we've seen several years
in a row here in New York is hemp down
you mildew if you grow other crops you
might have heard of Downing mildew in
cucurbits or other crops that you might
grow
here in hemp it's caused by the species
we first observed it here in New York in
and this species is most closely related
to cucurbit and hop down email juice
it only survives on plant tissue it's an
obligate biotroph meaning that the
pathogen itself means living plant
tissue to survive on
and the spores can spread via the wind
we don't know if it's c transmitted some
species of Downy mild used are we just
don't know enough about this yet
and like a lot of our other diseases it
thrives in cool wet conditions and then
we did see this again in 2021 in New
York and also Massachusetts
uh so the symptoms of hemp again mildew
it first infects the underside of the
leaf tissue and you'll see this gray
sporulation on the underside uh hence
the name Downey on the down underside of
the leaf eventually it will move to the
upper surface it kind of travels
directly through the leaf so by the time
that you see these lesions on the upper
surface of the leaf the underside is
probably heavily colonized
empty only mildew
produces sporangia which are the asexual
spores these spores can move through uh
water and wind to germinate on other
leaves and then it does have these
overwintering o spores that can survive
on Leaf litter in the soil and cause the
disease year to year
our lab is currently working on some
research projects studying Hampton
mildew someone is screening germplasm
for resistance
to hemp down your mildew we're
collecting isolates across the region to
study pathogen diversity
um and how diverse this pathogen is
um as well as looking for control
strategies which is our ultimate goal
for all of our disease research
um things that you can do to prevent
hemp Danny mildew are reducing Leaf
wetness by pruning removing leaves and
increasing their flow
so for the last portion of this talk I'd
like to focus on Research results from
our own lab
I'll focus on two projects here one on
powdery mildew completed by Ali Cala who
recently graduated and my own work on
pithium damping
so powdery mildew is a very common
fungal pathogen of hemp that you often
see in greenhouses controlled
environment agriculture as well as in
the field
it's caused by the fungal species
golovino mysis ambrosia
and powdery mildew as the name suggests
forms this white powdery mildew across
the top of the leaf surface if you zoom
in closer you'll see these long chains
of spores under the microscope are
actually all these asexual spores that
stack on top of each other
these spores are then wind dispersed and
easily move from plant to plant so if
you're moving between planting areas
you can easily take this with you
and uh like Downing mildew powdery
mildew also needs living plant tissue to
survive I should mention that this is
primarily found on the upper surface of
the plant
um but can really infect All Above
Ground parts of the plant
you can see a colonists of flowers
sometimes but you'll usually first
observe it on the upper surface of the
leaves
powdery mildew prefers hot humid
conditions
but dry leaves so unlike some pathogens
that require Leaf wetness in order to
disperse powdery mildew spores the
asexual spores will burst when they
encounter water so it likes high
humidity but a dry Leaf surface which
makes greenhouses a really great spot
for powdery mildew outbreaks to occur
um our lab has conducted some fungicide
efficacy trials
where the goal is to compare the
efficacy of some products currently
labeled in New York state for use on
them to control hemp Audrey mildew
and we also wanted to know whether
powdery mildew infection itself
or excuse me or a fungicide treatment
would affect cannabinoid production in
hemp flowers
so we didn't know prior to this if
diseases themselves can alter
cannabinoid production and this can vary
between different diseases or whether
these products we are applying might
impact cannabinoid reduction as well
so the products tested in this trial
included two biological products
lifeguard and Double Nickel so Matrix of
potassium silicate product as well as a
treatment alternating between lifeguard
and Double Nickel we used azoxy strobin
as a conventional positive control
however that's not currently labeled for
hemp we were just able to use it in a
research context
and then we compared all this to our
non-trio controls of course
so these studies were carried out in
2020 and 2021
um since it's a an obligate biotroph we
had to grow the inoculum on living
plants in growth Chambers we then washed
off the spores from leaves of those
plants and spray inoculated plant tissue
in the field
plants were inoculated three different
times in order to ensure infection
and then the disease severity was rated
five times once a week where the percent
disease coverage was Quantified and this
allowed us to calculate what we refer to
as audpc or the area under the disease
progress curve so that's essentially a
measurement of how the how the disease
progresses over the course of a growing
season and the greater the value the
greater the disease is
at the end of this growing season we
collected mature inflorescences
or cannabinoid analysis
here this graph is showing the data from
2020 where we use the cultivar TJ's CBD
High CBD variety
on the x-axis are the different
fungicide treatments and then on the
y-axis is our disease severity rating
the audpc the greater the value on the
y-axis indicates a greater disease
severity so we can see that our
untreated controls have the greatest uh
average disease severity
and then all of our fungicide treatments
did decrease disease severity at least
numerically anything sharing a letter
above it represents statistically
indistinguishable
treatments whereas those with different
letters are statistically different
significantly different
so cell Matrix our alternating treatment
Double Nickel and as oxystrobin all
significantly decreased the disease
present of pottery building
this was repeated in 2021 however using
a different cultivar white CBG which in
the year in between these two trials we
noticed was more susceptible to powdery
mildew so we went to see how do these
products perform when disease pressure
might be even greater
and again we saw the same thing where
entry control had the highest level of
hydro mildew infection and then our
fungicide treatments all seem to be
pretty effective lifeguard alone was not
statistically
um
significantly different from the entry
control however if you alternate
lifeguard and Double Nickel or use
double nickel or Soul Matrix alone you
saw a pretty good disease coverage and
this combined treatment might indicate
that Double Nickel itself is really
pulling most of the weight here and is a
very effective fungicide to use
when we looked at the potential
cannabinoid content of our
different treatments of the hemp and the
different treatments
similar graph where we have the
treatments on the x-axis here on the why
we have total potential CBD while there
are there seems to be a bit of a
gradient the Y scale here is actually
pretty narrow so there were no
significant differences between any of
the treatments
in any of the cannabinoids measured so
we Quantified CBD THC CVG and CBC
content
and like I said there were no
significant differences and cannabinoid
content in any of the fungicide
treatments in either our 2020 or 2021
trials so that's good
um you shouldn't be having to think
about fungicides you are applying
um to know whether they might impact
what your Harvest yields are
likewise when we looked at plants that
were just infected with powdery mildew
we saw no significant differences
between those infected with powdery
mildew or those that were non-ino
inoculated and this was true in both in
all of the cannabinoids measured THC CBD
CBG and CBC so the pathogen infection
itself wasn't um impacting the
cannabinoid content as well
so some conclusions and takeaways from
this fungicide efficacy work are that
some of the products that are available
for Growers to use now are effective in
reducing powdery mildew disease pressure
the two an hour study here that worked
quite well were still Matrix and Double
Nickel but they're I'm sure there's
other options available
fungicide treatments used in this
experiment did not impact cannabinoid
production in hemp and likewise powdery
mildew infection also did not affect
cannabinoid production
so another component of the powdery
mildew work completed was to identify if
there's any host resistance to powdery
mildew and hemp so here we surveyed a
broad genetic diversity of hemp of 30
cultivars and there were two sites of
this and two different on both of our
campuses here in New York and Geneva and
so here each graph represents one of the
growing locations so here was our
research field in Geneva and on the
right is our research Field in ethica
as you can see
um so on the y-axis is the mean percent
of diseases per plant so essentially
disease severity
um and there's a very wide range of
disease severity across our different
cultivars some of them having
practically no disease While others are
very heavily colonized with powdery
mildew
so this information is very useful for
plant breeders to identify genes of
interest that might control
disease resistance that can be
incorporated into future breeding lines
so in these field trials we've
identified at least one potential source
of post-resistance which is currently
being used in the Cornell breeding
program it's a breed for genetic
resistance to powdery mildew and hemp
we're continuing to screen for
additional genotypes to allow us to
identify other sources of genetic
resistance and this information will
also go to the breeding program
learning more about the pathogen itself
is critical we don't really know how the
pathogen overwinters or if it sexually
reproduces knowing more about the
biology can allow us to better inform
our management strategies
we've tested several products for
powdery mildew control
and all have been effective if they are
applied prior to the arrival of the
pathogen this is really important if
you're trying to apply a fungicide after
you already see infection it's often too
late that's not always the case but it's
fairly common especially when you're
using biofangicides they need to be
applied very early in the season and
prior to infection
um we were also interested in
determining what The Host range of hemp
powdery mildew is
so other powdery mildews there's powdery
mild is found on many many different
plant species
others often have a very narrow host
ranges but there were reports of the
species that infects hemp colabianomysis
ambrosia
um infecting some other
uh plant species
such as sunflowers okra and Zinnia
and similarly well interestingly there
have been reports of EQ carpet powdery
mildew species on hemp so we want to
test uh how true this is how far it
extends
so in this field trial in 2021
22 different cultivars of plants were
inoculated with colavinomyces Ambrosia
the hemp powdery mildew pathogen and
these included cucurbits Zinnia okra and
sunflowers
um like our other fungicide trials they
were rated for disease severity this
time five times throughout the growing
season and our audpc or disease Ferry
was calculated over the course of that
growing season
we then collected powdery mildew DNA
to identify the species causing the
infection so we want to see if what we
were inoculating the plants with was
indeed what we were seeing at the end of
the growing season when infection was
Heavy
um or if something else was moving in
naturally
so uh some of the summary data from
these experiments showed that yes all of
these different uh plant species are
susceptible to hemp powdery mildew
however we saw great differences between
cultivars within these crops so for
example here on the left in Okra one
species was much more susceptible than
the other and this was seen in all the
different crops that were tested
so while they might be susceptible
there could be great variation depending
on what cultivars you're using
some of the important takeaways from our
Host range trial
where that hemp powdery mildew caused by
golovinomyces Ambrosia has relatively
wide Host range including okra sunflower
hemp Sun hemp Zinnia and some cucurbits
while cucurbits can be a host of
globinomyces Ambrosia the hemp powdery
mildew another powdery mildew species
patofsprazanthi
was collected from more of the cucurbits
than we collected the hemp battery
multi-frame so this podocular species is
the powdery mildew that is primarily
seen on cucurbits and this is what we
were isolating back out from cucurbits
that were infected with powdery mildew
so this is showing that um
this pathogen spread in naturally and uh
most likely out competed the species
that we were inoculating with
there's differences in susceptibility to
go looking atomyces Ambrosia among our
different cultivars
um so this is important information to
think about what you're planting next to
each other if you have hemp and you're
concerned about powdery mildew you might
not want to plant some cultivars of
sunflowers for example that are very
susceptible and can bring in more
powdery mildew
um and then finally I'd like to move on
to my own dissertation work on pythium
dampenov
so like I mentioned previously with
pythium it's an oh myc pathogen here on
the bottom left
and these are two healthy seedlings with
quite long roots and then these top two
were inoculated with lithium and as you
can see they really did not get very far
before the plant fully died and did not
develop extensive roots
here is just a healthy flat of hemp
seedlings growing compared to those
inoculated with lithium so this pathogen
is really capable of completely wiping
out seedlings
this is often seen in Greenhouse
production where you have small plants
growing so maybe if you're growing hemp
baby greens this is a pathogen that you
might be more concerned about where
there's high moisture content and young
very susceptible plants
um so while pythm damping off came
because by many different species of
pythium one that I focused on was pythia
muriatula which was first reported on
hemp in Connecticut in 2018
symptoms include wilting of the leaves
necrotic lesions on the root roots and
then the outer cortex of the roots will
Slough off from the inner
vasculature of the root system
and if this progresses long enough
your seedling will damp off and die and
this whole process doesn't take very
long in very young seedlings
it's a soil dwelling water mold that
affects the root cap of the plant so
again this really prefers cool wet
conditions these are the sporangia
similar to this Brandy that we saw in
Downey mildew these uh produced the
swimming asexual spores that can move
through the water
so part of my research is determining
whether we can control soil-borne
pathogens via seed treatments
the objective of this work was to
determine if current fungicide seed
treatments available improved
germination and seedling viability on
both uninoculated or inoculated seeds
with pythia muriadulum and we also
included epithium ultimum another
species of pythium that causes damping
off
here I tested three different fungicide
seed treatments there was americop which
is a copper hydroxide product
probio oil probio ultim which I'll refer
to as pbu
is another copper hydroxide product and
then a phosphite product prudent 44 in
neutral
and here we use the hemp cultivar Vega
which and these seeds were all treated
here at Cornell
um in this experiment I sewed the seeds
directly into the styrofoam trays which
were then placed in the Basin of water
where the lithium inoculum was directly
added so this system was used so that we
could ensure pythium infection like I
said this really needs a wet environment
to survive
so by adding the inoculum into this
water we were able to get a heavy
infection
and then so we had flats that were
inoculated with lithium periodulum
lithium ultimum or that were left not
inoculated and all of the different seed
treatments were included in each of the
inoculum sources
for 22 days the number of germinated
seeds seedlings which died
post-emergence were damped off and the
number of healthy seeds were recorded
here are two Flats at the end of this
experiment here on the left is a flat
that was inoculated with lithium ultimum
where you can see drastically reduced
root development and a lot of dead
necrotic tissue
in the shoots whereas compared to the
uninoculated flat there's extensive root
growth and healthy green seedlings
growing
these two graphs show the percentage of
healthy seedlings here on the left we're
looking at 13 days post inoculation
on the y-axis is just the percentage of
healthy seedlings and then here are bars
for the three different
inoculum types so the first two are the
two species of pythium plant synocularly
with those and then our non-inoculated
Flats uh 13 days post inoculation we
didn't see any statistical differences
between these treatments however
after 22 days we did see a significantly
reduced number percentage of healthy
seedlings in our epithium inoculated
treatments compared to the
non-inoculated control
so that's good that shows that our
inoculation strategies worked
and then when we look at the seed
treatment data
here each panel represents one of the
three different inoculum sources so
these first two are our two species of
lithium and then this on the right is
our non-inoculated group and then across
the x-axis here are the different
fungicide seed treatments on the y-axis
is the percentage of healthy seedlings
um so as represented by the NS notation
here not significant there were no
significant differences
um in any of the seed treatments
compared to the control so none of these
tea treatments statistically
significantly improved the percentage of
healthy seedlings at 13 days best
inoculation
when we jump ahead to 22 days post
inoculation we see that the uninoculated
groups remain much higher than those
inoculated but again we don't see any
significant differences when we compare
the untreated to those treated with the
fungicides we do however see some
numerical differences
um where americop and the pbu film coats
uh numerically at least improved some
healthy seedling rates
so in summary here both species of
pythium that we inoculated with reduce
the number of healthy seedlings through
damping off
none of the seed treatments tested
significantly increased the percentage
of healthy seedlings however like I
mentioned americop and pbu did
numerically increase the number of
healthy seedlings
these products will further be evaluated
in other environmental conditions in the
field here we like I showed these were
in very wet soils it'll be interesting
to see how these products perform in
field soils with other soil-borne
pathogens and natural sources of
inoculum
and then some general conclusions and
takeaways from this seminar
are that as you're probably guessing by
now hemp is susceptible to a very wide
array of pathogens
of all of bacteria fungi and oh my seeds
cultural practices are very important
these include things like sanitation
cleaning or farm equipment frequently
and any pruning material
increasing airflow that can prevent leaf
wetness from stagnant water sitting on
your leaves avoid planting in wet soils
rotate to crops that might be non-hosts
of problematic pathogens in your system
and use resistant cultivars if they are
available or when they become available
fungicides available are limited but the
number of registered products is growing
it's just very important to read and
follow all labels on your pesticide
products and ensure that the product is
approved for use in your location
with that I would like to thank all of
my funding sources you funded our lab
and all of our work here New York State
Ag and markets Empire State Development
Corporation and all of our collaborators
here at Cornell
and I would be happy to answer some of
the questions in the Q a box now
yeah thank you so much Patrick yeah
please feel free to open that box and go
through all the questions
so the first question here is why was
there not great correlation and variety
susceptibility at the two powdery mildew
testing locations
um so these were slightly indifferent
slightly different environments
um the varieties that were more
susceptible in one location
or generally more susceptible in the
other location they didn't necessarily
line up in the exact order but for
example the first light 58 that had very
low powdery mildew infection in one
location also had very low infection in
the other location even if it wasn't
number one they still generally lined up
but environmental conditions can always
impact some of those we see
um have there been any studies performed
that track the efficacy of applying
beneficial microbials generated from
actively aerated compost to use applied
to foliar surfaces as a preventative for
various pathogens
there's a lot of work currently
happening
with microbial
additives
um I'm not so sure about examples of
using compost teas
um
as preventatives for pathogens however
some of the products we tested are
biofungicides
um which can control I showed some
efficacy data for biofungicides
controlling powdery mildew and we're
also testing those for
um septoria control as well so there are
a lot of biological products
um
some of my upcoming work will be testing
uh beneficial microbials as well I think
a lot of that research is currently in
the works
are there any known instances with
utilizing biopesticides or beneficial
microbes that may cause end products to
fail compliance testing for total yeast
and mold or mycotoxins
that's a very interesting question
um so the short answer is uh
a lot of that isn't known there's
projects that are taking place very soon
my lab is going to be completing some
work
um seeing the longevity of microbial
products in the inflorescences and
leaves
um
and I believe that legislation is still
working out some of the thresholds of
um
what is compliant when using some of
those microbial products
um so if you're concerned about that you
can apply them earlier in the season
um and follow any post-harvest interval
recommendations at the
that the label might give you
but yeah a lot more of that information
will be coming
uh in the future
and someone said speaking of Sanitation
how did I clean seeds for these studies
um yeah so on the sea treatment slide I
think I had in the bullet point that the
seeds were cleaned and sized this
essentially referred to
that the seeds were sifted through the
sieve to give us a certain size seed so
anything that was below a certain
threshold wasn't being included
in these studies the seedlings weren't
sterilized prior if you're worried about
contaminated
seed Lots sometimes you can do heat
treatments or short soaks and diluted
bleach and then rinse your seeds well
but that's not always necessary
are there any studies focusing on
additional powdery mildew species other
than those mentioned in the literature I
have seen both golbinomyces Ambrosia and
golvinomyces feditious reported and at
times have seen these species synonymous
through fungal taxonomy databases do not
come to a consensus at this matter
yes so
um I actually eliminated that from the
slide for the sake of Simplicity but so
um Ali Cala was the student who
completed a lot of this work when she
first started her uh her PhD work uh the
hemp powdery mildew was characterized as
golovinomyces feditious
and that's where she saw the reports of
this powdery mildew infecting other
um plant hosts as well so the okra and
sunflowers and that's what sparked the
interest in that Host range study
um then taxonomist my college
mycologists have reclassified
this clade of goldeenum speditious to
ambrosia
um
so everything that we studied was
originally classified as fedicious and
then later grouped into ambrosia
so I believe that ambrogio is just the
updated term for that my taxonomists are
always arguing and things are Ever
Changing
so I certainly understand the uh
confusion and questions there
and that is the last of the questions I
have in the Q a box
um if there's anything else I would be
happy to answer
but otherwise I greatly appreciate all
of you coming to this talk and hope that
was helpful for you
thank you so much Patrick that was a
representation
um and thank you Larry and all of you
guys for joining us today for this
webinar
uh please join us in two weeks April
19th for our seventh webinar focus on
hemp Harvest by Stephen philpotts from
Chicago State University
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu